how's it going everybody it's Warren
happy New Year to everyone I hope
everyone had a great night last night
this year's going to be amazing for
Marvel fans for DC fans and we even have
season two of the mandalorian coming out
as well so this video is going to be a
little different than normal I'm just
gonna talk about why phase four and this
year of 2020 is going to be so important
to the MCU who is coming to the MCU and
what is coming to my channel in 2020 and
of course I will announce the Infinity
Gauntlet and G filled giveaway winners
at the end of this video as well so lots
of major things are going to be
happening in 2020 I know I talk a lot
about things that are coming in Phase
five but there really are a lot of
really important things coming in phase
four now there are a lot of
possibilities for these upcoming movies
and shows it's looking like the
beginning of phase 4 with Black Widow
and the Falcon and Winter Soldier series
is going to be setting up the
Thunderbolts the Thunderbolts are a
really awesome group and this is really
big because the MCU at the start of
phase 4 isn't going to have an Avengers
team Disney CEO Bob Iger has already
stated that in phase 4 we are living in
a post Avengers world so right away when
we start off with phase 4 it there's not
going to be an Avengers team but what
looks like is happening is the
Thunderbolts are being set up there's
also evidence that suggests that Black
Widow could possibly introduce the very
first mutant to the MCU that mutant is
Ursa Major and this will start the
mutants being in the MCU which would
eventually introduce the x-men and this
leads us to the Eternals the Eternals
are another team we don't have the
Avengers but we are getting many
different teams in the MCU not only is
the Eternals going to be a completely
different MCU film than we've ever seen
before but they are also probably going
to explore mutants as well the
Celestials are godlike beings who
created the Eternals and how the
Eternals were created were essentially
genetic mutations and experiments done
on humans the Celestials created the
human race and in turn they created the
Eternals and mutants as well at least
that's looking how it's going to be
played off so these three movies in the
start of 2020 and phase four are going
to be incredibly important and are going
to set up the future of the MCU phase
four and 2020 are going to be absolutely
incredible
for the MCU same thing with my channel I
have lots of big plans for 2020 I've
written down a bunch of ideas that I
have planned for 2020 and I've listened
to a ton of audiobooks about YouTube and
in fact I'm going to be doing a
challenge issued by audible the
challenge that they have issued is to
listen to three audiobooks by March 3rd
of 2020 and if you do that you get a
twenty dollar credit for amazon.com many
of you have asked me for YouTube advice
before about starting channels are
helping current channels and if you want
to do this challenge I recommend
listening to YouTube secrets by Sean
canal and Benji Travis I just got done
listening to this channel Sean Canales
well-known in the industry and it's
great information for people who want to
start a YouTube channel or to help grow
their own YouTube channel if you want to
listen to this audiobook or do audibles
challenge you can do it for free because
they offer a 30-day free trial and if
you're an audible member you get access
to three free audiobooks a month one
audiobook and two exclusive audible
originals that you can't hear anywhere
else you can go to audible.com slash
cosmic Wonder for the audible 30-day
free trial and they also have a lot of
audiobooks about fitness about finance
really whatever your goals are for the
new year they have an audiobook for it
so again you can go to audible.com slash
cosmic Wonder for the 30 day free trial
and I'm also going to be starting a
personal channel pretty soon where I'll
talk about YouTube and give advice on it
as well so stay tuned for that but let's
talk about the rest of phase 4 it's
sounding like shang-chi is going to be
an absolutely incredible movie but from
everything I've heard so far it doesn't
sound like it's going to connect too
much with all of the other MCU films or
shows however something major that is
happening is we are going to have two
different Disney plus series and two
different MCU films connect to each
other in a major way each film or show
is going to severely affect what happens
in the films or shows to come the one
division series Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness the Loki series
and Thor love and thunder are all going
to connect to each other in a big way
the one division series is going to
truly introduce the Scarlet Witch this
has been confirmed they're going to call
her The Scarlet Witch for the very first
time in the MCU during the show we're
also going to really see her be an
actual witch of course she got her
powers from the mine stone but in the
series we're going to see her tap more
to her powers we've already seen leaked
photos that show the Salem witch trials
and that show a character that is widely
believed to be Agatha Harkness Agatha
Harkness and the comics is the one who
teaches her and trains her how to use
her magical powers and then it looks
like there's going to be a major villain
introduced in the Wanda vision series
that is going to tie in to Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness
this could be Doctor Doom doctor dooms
mother was a witch and dr. doom himself
goes on to eventually become one of the
most powerful sorcerers the world has
ever seen and it has been reported that
dr. doom is making his way into the MCU
soon being built up as the next big bad
villain and actually I forgot to mention
that in the Eternals tyrant is supposed
to be introduced as well and tyrant was
once upon a time a Herald of Galactus
who is supposed to be set up as the next
main big bad as well there's supposed to
be two big bad villains but then going
into Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness this film is supposed to be an
extremely important film Kevin Feige
himself has recently came out and said
that this film is going to introduce
characters that they've been wanting to
introduce for a very long time some of
whom are widely believed to be mutants
as well
I actually was given a really awesome
inside scoop about this from Mikey
Sutton I'm posting a video about it
Friday so be sure to look out for that
but Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to completely change
the way the MCU is and like I said this
is going to go on to affect the Loki
series Thor love and thunder and even
phase 5 phase 6 all of the future phases
the MCU is really getting more exciting
than it's ever been before so my goal is
to bring you new refreshing videos about
the MCU and of course about other
superhero topics as well I've been doing
a lot of origin videos lately tying in
lakes to origins in the comics and a lot
of you have said that you've really
enjoyed it so I'm going to try to do
more of those videos I'm going to
actually start doing some fanfiction on
my channel the Marvel what-if series is
coming up and it's really cool to kind
of just say well what if this happened
and I think it would be kind of a cool
way to geek out with each other and talk
about what we think would happen if
certain things went a different way in
the MCU and I'm also going to be
starting back up my podcast this may be
a live podcast set in a certain day a
week and I'm going to try to have
special guests appear in each
Podcast and i've also started a discord
that I'll be sharing with everybody soon
so we can all engage with each other as
one big community but all right the
moment you've all been waiting for the
Infinity Gauntlet and G fuel giveaway
just to reiterate three runner-up
winners are going to receive a tub of G
fuel and an infinity shaker and then the
grand prize winner is going to receive
an Infinity Gauntlet and infinity shaker
and a tub of G fuel
I'll draw four winners from the website
the first winner will get the overall
grand prize and the next three will be
the runners-up all right here we go
there was a total of 2013 entries and
the winners are congrats to Aidan
Spencer you have won the Infinity
Gauntlet along with an infinity shaker
and a tub of G fuel and congrats to the
Big Bear to soo bum tri pathy and joe
corporal you each receive an infinity
shaker and a tub of G feel as well thank
you all so much for entering it seems
like you all really enjoyed this contest
so I'll do another one pretty soon again
I hope it's going to be an amazing year
I have lots of plans for my channel also
some other channels I'm starting as well
so stay tuned as always I want to say
thank you all so much for the support
that you've shown me and shown my
channel and I hope you enjoy the videos
that I put out this year as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof